people that you would not expect to lead
or leading like Kanye West people who
you would expect to lead like for
instance a an English Prince Prince
Harry Duke of Sussex is not leading
Prince Harry posted the most cringe
inducing video over the weekend that
I've seen in quite a while it ended up
looking like a hostage tape where Prince
Harry apologized for all of the
institutional racism and don't forget
that is just a code word for for bad all
the badness and by the way if the
English monarchy is not an institution I
don't know what is so I guess he would
have to be responsible for this here we
probably always viewed himself as a good
guy we always thought he's fine and no
we don't think he's some bigot but he
has to apologize for the institutional
racism it was very very pathetic
my wife said recently the our generation
and the ones before us I - I'm sorry
sorry that we haven't got the world to
the place that you deserve it to be
institutional racism has no place in our
societies yet it is still endemic
unconscious bias must be acknowledged
without blame to create a better world
for all of you I want you to know that
we are committed to being part of the
solution and to being part of the change
that you are now is the time and we know
that you can do it
my wife said recently that's you could
have stopped the video there and you
would have said this is not going to be
a good video pretty embarrassing stuff
that the Duke of Sussex has to begin his
own speeches by saying you know my wife
just told me this is my wife that's very
interesting thing and you know my wife
told me to give this speech by the way
and so that's what my wife said love her
she's great
pathetic very pathetic stuff but when
leaders don't lead then things go a
little bit haywire and I think that's
that's what you've been seeing the
madness and the mayhem and the rioting
not just in the US but also in the UK
all around the world
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description